hello freak [ __ ] well you're also
very concerned with AI as well right
artificial intelligent yeah that's
exactly like and that's I think in this
category of if you look at the history
of human progress technological change
just creates these huge step changes in
just how humanity progresses it was only
twelve years
in nineteen ninety nineteen thirty three
to the nineteen forty five between Leo
Szilard first coming up with the idea of
the nuclear chain reaction and that was
just a purely conceptual idea in a bit
of paper
twelve years from that to then the
deployment of the first nuclear bomb and
think how radical a change that is
having suddenly being a nuclear age that
was only twelve years
yeah we went over the the invention of
the airplane to dropping an atomic bomb
out of the airplane I believe it was
fifty years right yeah I'm more in the
neighborhood of 50 years yeah is it not
take a few yeah so technological
progress can suddenly go in these huge
leaps that we're not prepared for the
well off is very not prepared for
and I think artificial intelligence is
in this category you where we're really
making a radical progress on RNA I
especially over the last five years it's
really one of the fastest developing
technologies I think and yet has huge
potential in so many different ways and
as with any new technology huge positive
potential really if you get AI right you
can solve almost any other problem but
also potential risks as well where
there's a risks that might be more
familiar you know worries about
automation unemployment worries about
autonomous weapons which I think should
be taken seriously and then also just
worries about well what if we really do
manage to make human level artificial
intelligence very good arguments that
would then quickly move to superhuman
level artificial intelligence and what
then are we now in a situation like the
Neanderthals of versus Homo sapiens
where we suddenly created this
intelligence that is greater than our
own are we able to control that are we
able to ensure that transition is
positive rather than negative
have you ever considered the possibility
when you look at all the impoverished
people in the world all the cruelty all
the people that were so just concerned
with material possessions and shallow
thinking and war and just evil that men
do is it possible that we are sort of an
outdated concept that what we are as
these biological organisms that are
still slaves to the whole Darwinian
evolutionary survival of the fittest
natural selection sort of paradigm that
we've operated under for all these many
thousands and hundreds of thousands of
years as humans is it possible that
we're giving birth to the next thing
that just like we don't long for the
days when we used to be monkeys throwing
[ __ ] at each other from the trees one
day we will be something different
whether it would be a combination of us
and these machines or whether we're
going to augment our own intelligence
with some sort of artificial whether
it's some sort of an EXO brain or
something that is going to take us in or
it's going to be simply that we create
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence no longer has use for us
because we're illogical and then that
becomes a new life-form yeah then we're
lost hide in the cave somewhere hoping
the terminators don't get us yeah I mean
I think like over the long term I mean
with all of these things the question is
kind of timelines is very hard and
sometimes people want to reject this
sort of discussion because oh this is so
far in the future whereas I think like
if something sufficiently important we
should be talking about it even if maybe
it's you know decades of generations
hence why not be right I mean it might
not be that far away but who knows like
with the atomic bomb that was hugely
fast progress just you know twelve years
so we want to be prepared but then how
so like yeah is it going to be Homo
sapiens around for the next you know in
a thousand years time I think they would
just be extremely unlikely that we'll be
around you think we're not gonna be
around anymore yeah I mean I think if
intelligent creatures are still around
it's going to be some in a thousand
years time it's going to be something
that's not
Homo sapiens like he said this kind of
free oh it's like not what we would
consult consider kind of typical humans
now well we're obviously severely flawed
right I mean if we like if you ask
people if you ask the average average
person do you think that in your
lifetime you can imagine a world without
war
most people say now look the vast
majority people say no were a world
without crime a world without violence
a world without theft most people say no
mmm-hmm that's that this shows you how
inherently flawed most people view the
human species you know we know that we
can do it in small groups you know like
if the three of us were on an island I'm
pretty sure we wouldn't be stealing from
each other and murdering each other
right actually that few of us but when
you get to large-scale humanity becomes
very easy to disassociate or create this
diffusion of responsibility where
there's you know enough people so you
don't really value them as much and
you're allowed to get away with some
pretty heinous stuff especially when you
consider drone warfare things that were
able to do long distance where we're not
seeing the person that we're having the
effect on yes we did it's a very flawed
thing the human species wouldn't be
better if something better came along I
mean I think this yeah I'm Laura yeah I
think not good friend I though not well
we'd be obsolete yeah I mean well we're
we're going to be obsolete in 100 years
anyway I mean as in we'll be dead right
so what the question is just we'll all
kind of generations hence well you know
not the questions not really about us
it's about our grandchildren what really
forces the idea to be considered like
what is valuable about life like is it
the experience is it happiness is it
shared fun is it love like what is
what's valuable about being a person and
how much of that is going to change if
we're made out of something that people
have created or or maybe we're made out
of something artificial intelligence has
created because we've created something
that's far superior to us so yeah I mean
I have a view and this as you might
expect where I mean in my view from the
thing that's valuable and the only thing
out that's valuable ultimately is
conscious
experience so that's good positive like
Road conscious experiences happy
happiness joy and so on that's positive
that's good for the world how negative
conscious experience is suffering pain
despair those are bad for the world and
so that's why you know it's a good thing
for me to do some service to you to
benefit you but I can't do anything good
to benefit this bottle of water right
and so then the key question in terms of
what should we think about supposing is
the case that you know thousand years
time is now synthetic life it's
artificial intelligence or something
that's the people like that are in
charge and are no longer any humans
would this be good or bad the question
for me is you know are they having
conscious experiences and all those
conscious experiences good or bad so
that's it just conscious experience yeah
so it's a consequential selfish it's a
controversial view there's a thought
experiment which is often used to
challenge this view do you want to hear
that yes so it's called the experience
machine and the idea is supposing that
tomorrow you could plug into this
machine like the most amazing VR you
could ever have and in this machine you
will live for let's say you live for 200
years and you'll be in the most amazing
bliss you'll have the most amazing
experiences of you know and your
experiences will involve incredible
relationships incredible creative
achievement and so on and it'll just be
like the perfect life that you could
live experientially for the next 200
years and the question is insofar as you
are self-interested so put aside
considerations you might have about
wanting to make the world a better place
but just insofar as you care about
yourself
would you plug into this thing bearing
in mind that in a certain sense all of
these experiences going to be fake
you're going to have experiences of
having amazing friendships when great
works Lawtons connect even great works
of art and so on but they're they're not
going to be a real is just sensory
inputs provided by a computer right so
the question is would you or ought you
insofar as yourself interested
plug into this machine what would you
answer that's a very good question
I might already be plugged into it right
I mean you know so this is this is a
great question right and I think it's a
good argument against is the question
well supposing you were already plugged
in would you unplug supposing I told you
that actually you're a banker than
Monaco and [ __ ] Monaco I just I'm not
interested in that no I want to stay
right here yeah so can I stay plugged in
please do I have to pay more what have
to do you would have to do nothing
interesting man if people think so most
people and it seemed like maybe yourself
would intuitively to say no I wouldn't
plug into this machine I don't know if I
would say that I would have to really
deeply consider because right now it's
just so it's so abstract this idea that
that could be possible so it's it's
fantasy we're having fun but when you
talk to the leading minds when it comes
to virtual reality or artificial reality
or simulation Theory you know when they
start talking about what will be
possible one day they're going to
without a doubt within a hundred years
or five hundred years or whatever the
number is they're going to be able to
create an artificial reality is
indiscernible from this reality you're
going to be able to feel things there's
going to be emotions that come to you
you're going they're going to be able to
recreate every single aspect of in
everyday life just a matter of time I
mean they're really close now not not
really close in terms of like they don't
give you emotions and I don't give you
feeling but if you put on an HTC vive
and go through some of those virtual
reality games I mean it's bizarre how
real it feels yeah yeah and when you go
back to like playing pong did you ever
play pong yeah you know it's such a
weird thing that that happened inside
about my when I was a kid pong came
along we were blown away yeah we
couldn't believe that we could actually
do something on the television you could
see it move it was so fantastic and if
you gave that to one of my kids they'd
spit on it they'd be like what kind of
piece of [ __ ] video game is this like
they would think it's just so ridiculous
but to me at the time it was amazing
you go from that to one of these HTC
vive games which is all taking place
within on my lifetime and you go well a
lifetime from now if you follow the
exponential increase in the ability the
technological innovation it's going to
be spectacular it's going to be
absolutely so when that does happen how
will you be able to know if it's
indiscernible how will you know if
you're in it and how do you know if
you're not in it right now
that's the real question right yeah I
mean they're actually some arguments for
thinking you know this is Nick Bostrom a
colleague of mine a simulation argument
for thinking we are in a situation right
now in fact it's very likely that we
should be yeah that would I that I
actually I'm kind of agnostic I think
you should take that the hypothesis
seriously but I think the the argument
doesn't quite go through for what's
attractive and was not attractive about
that theory of you okay so his version
of it yeah so the argument is the frame
and if you could like said yeah yeah
yeah so his argument is the in the
future supposing we believe that the
human race doesn't go extinct or post
unions don't go extinct over the next
two thousand years and secondly the the
people in the future have an interest in
recreating their past just for kind of
historical interest or for learning so
they're going to be insisting running
sync because then I got now gonna have
huge amazing computer power they're
going to be able to create simulations
of the past that they're going to have
some interest in running simulations of
the past well the number of if that is
true than the number of simulations that
these future people are going to be
running will vastly outnumber the number
of actual timelines the kind of base
universe as it were so for the one real
universe where history kind of unfolds
is also let's call it you know 10,000
simulations of that universe and if
that's true then it's the case that well
given that I'm just you know these
things where we are indiscernible for
the people who are inside them is
overwhelmingly likely just in the
baseplate that I'm going to be in a
simulation rather than
in the real world and what nick bostrom
says actually is not that we definitely
are in a simulation but he just points
out the conflict between these three
kind of beliefs that we seem to hold one
is that we're not going to go extinct in
your future two is that people in the
future will have some interest in
simulating the past and thirdly that
we're not living in a simulation and he
himself gives you know a reasonable
degree of belief maybe he thinks it like
ten percent likely fifteen percent
likely that within a simulation other
people who understand the argument vary
a bit more but I think you know it's
something you should at least be taking
seriously the reason I reject it is kind
of even weirder I think it's somewhat
technical but the basic thought is just
um according to likes best guesses from
cosmologists were actually in an
infinite universe the universe is
infinitely big now we can't affect an
infinitely big universe where it was
stricted by the speed of light to what
we can affect unto what we can see but
the best idea according to the best
theory we have universities kind of
keeps on going but if so then there's
already like an infinite number of
observers of people kind of in that
bottom universe and that means that
you've now got kind of an infinite
number of people kind of experiencing
things and then you've got the
simulations
you've got like ten thousand simulations
but you can't say those ten thousand met
times as many simulated beings as there
are real beings because there's only an
infinite number of real beings you're
looking so good
constantly no no no go ahead keep down
but that means if you've got so the key
of the opossums argument was that you've
got ten thousand times as many simulated
beings as you have real like non
simulated beings but our problem is is
an infinite number of real beings
because the universe is infinite yeah
that's right and so if you've already
got an infinite number of real beings
the fact that you've got 10,000 times
infinite that's still infinite
right you can't it's kind of a case
where like our best methods of assigning
degrees of belief to things kind of run
out if you think it's you know there's
an infinite number of simulated beings
an infinite number of real beings then
what's the chance of you being one or
the other I mean it like we don't
actually have the elec tools to be able
to answer that Neil deGrasse Tyson was
trying to explain this to me a couple of
weeks ago that there are infinities that
are bigger than other infinities yes so
that's all for the case but yeah that
was right world my brain and yeah so the
number but the key we're all talking
about the lowest was called cardinality
the smallest infinity mm-hmm which is
the size of the infinity of all the
integers 1 2 3 4 orienting numbers and
if you take that size of infinity and
multiply it by 10,000 let's say you just
get the same number which is infinity
right and then what Neil was saying was
yeah though these even bigger levels of
infinity so if you look at not just all
the counting numbers but all of the
numbers you can make fractions out of
1/2 1/4 1/8 and so on that's a bigger
that's just more numbers than the
infinity of the counting numbers I've
spent a lot of time trying to understand
why human beings are so obsessed with
innovation why human beings are so
obsessed with technological progress and
one of the things that I continue to
come to is that we think of everything
in this world as being natural but the
behavior of butterflies and wolves and
the way rivers run down from the
mountain but we don't think of ourselves
in our own behavior as natural we don't
think of our own thirst for conquest and
innovation and and the even materialism
I think materialism is probably a very
natural reaction to our need to somehow
or another fuel innovation and that one
of the ways to ensure that innovation is
constantly fueled is that people are
constantly obsessed with buying new
things constantly obsessed with the
latest and greatest which fuels
innovation and when you look at the
universe itself and you
look at all the various things that we
know to be natural processes in the
universe like like in order to make a
human being star has to explode when you
literally are made out of Stardust just
when you run that by people for the
first time they go wait what like in
order to heat you for you to have
carbon-based life form that has to be
created inside a burning dying star and
that's the only way you make this thing
like what you are right now and then
that thing makes artificial reality and
then that thing makes perhaps even
crazier makes I mean if you follow the
ideas of technological progress if
something gets to a point where it's
indiscernible from reality how do you
know it's not a new reality how do you
know it's not a new kind of reality like
Jaime sent me hip to these artificial
worlds that people have created it
online where they're essentially
infinite and they're constantly changing
and morphing and growing and the games
are terrible people don't like them
because you go you go to places and
there's [ __ ] nothing there yeah and
you can go to an infinite number of
these places and there's not something
like these adventures are non-existent
so you're on these you're in these
gigantic fake worlds where you're
traveling from place to place but right
now we're looking at it in a very
two-dimensional way you're looking at it
on flat screen one day it's not going to
be two-dimensional one day it's going to
be something that you are interfacing
with your consciousness is interfacing
with it is it only real if we can take
it and drop it on something if we can
hit it with a hammer if we could put it
on a scale we're gonna use a measuring
stick and measuring is it only real
there or is it real if it follows every
single check like if you check off every
single item on the list of conscious
reality and conscious experience yeah I
think that's a great question because I
think the dichotomy that a lot of people
think in terms of natural non natural I
think it's just meaningless
I mean people firstly think this is
natural missus not I mean in a sense
everything we're doing is natural
because we're like Homo sapiens a part
of the natural process
and in another maybe in another sense
everything we're doing is not natural
but then why does that matter what's the
model relevance of something being
natural versus not natural right lots of
stuff that happens in the natural world
is just really awful huge amount of
cannibalism they might like yeah
murder shuffling so it's not clear why
we would care about something being
natural well non natural but then the
second question is yeah let's consider
this virtual reality again this
experience machine that you could plug
yourself into and as part of the
description I said oh none of this would
be real you have all of these
interactions with people that you think
are friends and so on
but that wouldn't be a real and I think
you could very well push back on that
and say why should something be
physically instantiated like in order
for it to count as the real experience
right why is it not the case that in
this virtual reality you're interacting
with algorithms but that's just as much
at least it's possible for that to be
just as much fun ship as if you are
interacting with people who are you know
flesh-and-blood and I think it's hard to
explain kind of what the difference
would be because you know if you think
about Star Trek Kim Jong lepra car can
be cleansers data and Android use not
kind of bio biological but you know we
think that you can still have kind of
normal worth and friendships and so on
with features that are not made of kind
of human biology in which case why is
the fact that something merely lives on
silicone why would that always kind of
seemingly merely software what does that
mean you couldn't have kind of a genuine
friendship with that thing if it the if
it acts and sufficiently sophisticated
way perhaps
[Applause]
[Music]